the movie opens with a brief background
into the world of payam a nation divided
into 12 districts ruled with an Iron
Fist from the capital years ago a failed
Rebellion against the capital was met
with a brutal punishment each year each
district must offer two children aged
between 12 and 18 in an event called The
Reaping then the children are
transported to the capital for a
televised fight to the death called The
Hunger Games The Lone Survivor then
becomes the Victor and is free to go
back to their District after the brief
history lesson we meet Cesar flickerman
the flamboyant host of the games
interviewing the head game maker senaka
crane about the upcoming 74th Hunger
Games meanwhile in the impoverished
District 12 young Katniss everan lives
with her mother and younger sister
Primrose ever since their father's death
Katniss has become the rock of the
family providing both emotional and
practical support one day young Prim has
a nightmare where she dreams that her
name was chosen for the Hunger Games
before Katniss goes out for a hunt she
soothes her younger sister down with the
local son Under The Willow Katniss
Ventures into the Forbidden Forest
crossing the electric fence that
confines The poverty-stricken District
12 coal mines dominate the landscape
reflecting The Bleak lives of the
struggling residents added by her Keen
hunting skills Katniss tracks down a
deer just as she prepares to shoot her
friend Gail Hawthorne interrupts
allowing the deer to escape however he
helps her bring down a bird to trade
with the peacekeepers a police force who
Patrol the streets on behalf of the
capital their Hunt is abruptly
interrupted by a colossal aircraft
hovering buff emerging from the ship is
Effie Trinket District 12's adviser who
is arriving to prepare for the reaping
children between 12 and 18 assemble in
Freedom Hall divided by their age groups
Effie plays a propaganda film glorifying
the capital before drawing a name from a
bowl prim's nightmare becomes reality
when her name is chosen as the girl
tribute witnessing her fragile sister's
selection for a brutal televised Death
Match Katniss steps forward volunteering
for District 12 this unexpected act
stuns Effie on the other hand Peta melar
is then chosen as the boy tribute as
Katniss and Peta shake hands we see
through a flashback scene that Katniss
has somewhere previously seen the boy
but the Memory Remains incomplete for
now Effy whisks the bewildered tributes
away on a highp speed train to the
capital for the first time the two kids
from District 12 witness true luxury a
spacious cabin adorned with mahogany
furniture and overflowing with food
they've never seen before Peta attempts
to initiate conversation with Katniss
triggering flashbacks of him feeding
pigs at his father 's Bakery however
Katniss completely ignores him on the
train they meet hch abery the sole
survivor of The Hunger Games from
District 12 a cynical alcoholic hch
offers two Bleak pieces of advice accept
the probability of their death and
understand that he cannot save them he
then retreats to his room with a glass
of liquor as a persistent Peta follows
him Katniss flashes back to a brutal
game seen casually displayed on
television later she joins Peta for
breakfast with hitch he emphasizes the
crucial role of sponsors wealthy
individuals who can send gifts during
the games and determine their survival
they soon approach the capital's train
station a stark contrast to District 12
technologically advanced spotless and
populated with people dressed beyond the
comprehension of their dirt covered
Hometown while Peta gleefully waves at
fans at the station a sarcastic hch
advises Katniss to keep a knife implying
Peta already knows how to win over the
crowd as their Capital Journey Begins
Katniss and Peta are cleaned and prepped
like cattle before meeting their stylist
C unlike the others C expresses genuine
empathy towards Katniss instead of
celebrating her forced participation in
the games he emphasizes the importance
of making a good impression and dresses
the tributes in shimmering clothes that
ignite with a vibrant flame at the
tribute parade held before President
Snow and a live audience of hundreds of
thousands their spectacular flaming
attire draws thunderous Applause
following the parade they are shown
their living quarters and begin their
intensive 4-day training on day one they
are warned about the dangers of natural
natural causes like dehydration and
exposure and encourag to listen to their
survival instincts during group
exercises Katniss observes several
exceptionally skilled kids from
wealthier districts who excel in combat
and strategy at dinner that night hch
reveals that these individuals are
career tributes from privileged
districts like one 2 and four these
careers train rigorously from a young
age and often form alliances during the
games this news demoralizes both
District 12 tributes particularly Peta
he points out Katniss's exceptional
hunting skills recalling her ability to
kill squirrels with a single shot
between the eyes in response Katniss
acknowledges peta's extraordinary
strength having witnessed him
effortlessly carry heavy flower bags at
his Bakery however it is PETA who shares
that even his mother believes catness
has the potential to win the games for
District 12 the dinner concludes on a
summer note with both tributes returning
to their rooms without finishing their
meals the next day during training the
careers continue to Showcase their
formidable combat skills initially Peta
struggles even with simple tasks like
climbing a rope net much to the
amusement of the careers however he
manages to impress them with a display
of his remarkable strength by
effortlessly throwing a heavy metal ball
additionally he shares his exceptional
camouflage abilities with Katniss next
we see Katniss at the evaluation where
she impresses the sponsors by hitting an
apple placed in a roasted Pig's mouth
with a single Arrow she then bows out
with a Curt greeting 3 days later the
results are announced and Katniss scores
around remarkable 11 out of 12
surpassing even careers like Marvin from
District 1 and Glimmer from District 2
Peta on the other hand receives a
respectable eight behind the scenes
President Snow expresses displeasure
upon learning that game master senica
gave Katniss such a high score he remind
senica that the games exist to solidify
the capitals control over the districts
by offering just a little glimmer of
hope not too much in the following scene
hitch informs Katniss that he will
accompany her to the interview on the
last day of training he also o reveals
that Peta insisted on training alone
which is common at this stage as
ultimately only one of them will survive
on the final day of training the ever
Charming Caesar flickerman hosts an
interview with all the tributes for the
televised audience Katniss now known as
the girl on fire thanks to her
impressive entrance at the parade
captivates the studio crowd with her
awkward yet honest answers and stunning
flaming dress meanwhile Peta already
known for his good looks launches a
charm offensive confidently expressing
his admiration for cat
backstage Katniss is initially upset by
this Revelation but sin trinket and hch
urge her to continue playing along as it
helps her secure sponsors later that
night Katniss discovers that peta's
feelings are genuine and not just a
performance for the cameras the day of
the games arrives as the tributes make
their way to the artificial Arena C
gifts Katniss the mocking jay pinned
badge she earlier gave to her sister
emerging from tubes into the arena the
tributa Cornucopia a horn-shaped canopy
overflowing with suppli placed at the
center when the buzzer signals the start
of the Games Katniss avoids the Frantic
Rush towards the Cornucopia and Sprints
into the forest with a bag of supplies
running and falling without catching her
breath she reaches the depths of the
forest climbs a tree and disappears from
the eyes of others however her Solitude
is short-lived soon the career group
composed of Marvel and Glimmer from
district one clo from District 2 and
their leader Gotto arrive laughing to
her surprise Peta appears to have joined
them in hopes of prolonging his Revival
by Nightfall roughly half the tributes
are dead their demise announced by a
haunting Cannon boom alone and terrified
Katniss manages to sleep on the tree
branch unaware of the capitals on to
present cameras observing her every move
the next morning Katniss awakens to a
raging forest fire engulfing the area
she leaps from the tree and fleas
towards the outskirts desperately trying
to remain hidden from the other tributes
however game maker senica directs
Fireballs towards her ultimately forcing
her into the open where the career group
spots her they chase her up a tree but
Peta intervenes urging them to wait
until she is forced down by hunger that
night while her pursuers sleep hch
through the sponsors sends Katniss a
gift a lotion to soothe her burned scars
as Dawn breaks Ru a young tribute from
District 11 skilled in climbing and
hiding signals Katniss to a nest of
deadly genetically engineered wasps
called tracker jackers above her head
Katniss swiftly cuts the branch holding
the nest sending it tumbling onto the
sleeping careers the Furious wasp swarm
glimmer killing her instantly while the
others scramble to escape unfortunately
Katniss suffers a sting herself and
while retrieving a bow and arrow from
glimmer body hallucinates about her
father's fatal mining accident Peter
rushes to her side urging her to flee
but Katniss succumbs to unconsciousness
upon waking several days later Katniss
discovers Ru has cared for her and
helped her heal Ru reveals that Peta is
still alive hiding down by the river
meanwhile the careers have gathered all
the supplies into a pyramid near the
Cornucopia laying traps around it to
lure unsuspecting survivors Katniss
hatches a daring plan Ru will create
distractions with fire while Katniss
detonates the supply pyramid a short
while later using a bag of apples and a
well-placed arrow Katniss successfully
destroys the stockpile however Ru is
captured during the chaos reacting
quickly Katniss frees Ru from a net only
to be attacked by Marvel from district
one he throws a spear at catness which
she narrowly Dodges and she retaliates
by shooting him in the chest with an
arrow but in a tragic turn of events the
deflected spear pierces through Ru
killing her in Katniss's arms grief
stricken but fueled by anger and
determination Katniss raises three
fingers towards the cameras a mocking J
symbol a symbol of defiance this act
coupled with the death of a young child
ignites a smallscale riot against the
peacekeepers in District 11 observing
this unfolding Drama Game Maker senak
plots to eliminate Katniss however a
cunning hch intervenes suggesting a rule
change that would allow two Victors if
they hail from the same distance
District this scheme would create a
compelling young lovers narrative
between Katniss and Peta likely boosting
television ratings nonetheless President
Snow warns senica against fueling any
sense of rebellion or empowerment in the
outer districts despite the warnings
senica announces the new rule allowing
two tributes from the same district to
be Victors provided that they survive
till the end this prompts Katniss to
locate Peta who is cleverly camouflaged
himself as a rock by the riverbank
unfortunately petal eyes severely
injured his leg ravaged by a sword wound
while the young couple displays
affection for the cameras another plot
twist arises senica announces a feast
near the cornicopia where crucial
supplies will be placed disregarding
peta's please Katniss slips away while
he sleeps determined to acquire the
medicine he desperately needs under the
harsh sunlight Katniss Witnesses fox
face the cunning girl tribute from
District 5 snatching her bag of supplies
and fleeing Katniss races towards the
bag Mark 12 and retrieves it but is
ambushed by Clove from District two
before she can escape holding a knife to
Katniss's throat clove boasts about
killing Ru in a sudden turn of events
thresh the male tribute from District 11
appears and kills cloven revenge for
Rue's death he spares Katniss
remembering Ru and disappears into the
woods clutching the medicine Katniss
hurries back to Peta miraculously by
morning the medicine has healed his
wounds The District 12 tributes venture
out together to hunt Peta predicts kot's
location near the cornicopia as he is
unfamiliar with the forest while Foxface
The elusive tribute from District 5
could be anywhere due to her remarkable
hiding skills to increase their chances
they split up to search for food just as
Katniss aims to shoot a bird a cannon
blast Echoes through the arena causing
her to rush back fearing the worst for
PETA she finds him unharmed but
unknowingly picking poisonous berries
thankfully he hasn't ingested any yet
however they soon discover the lifeless
body of Foxface who succumb to the
deadly berries back in the control
center head game maker senica hatches a
Sinister plan to expedite the game's
conclusion he accelerates the night
cycle and unleashes a pack of
genetically modified bloodthirsty hounds
into the arena soon thresh District 11's
last remaining tribute Falls victim to
their brutal attack barely escaping a
Hound's assault catniss and Peter race
towards the Arena's Center where they
find themselves cornered by the pack
they scramble up the Cornucopia where an
injured kado awaits them as they fight
precariously on the structure kot's
demeanor seems to soften perhaps shaken
by the BL shed and hatred he witnessed
in the games ultimately Katniss and Peta
gain the upper hand and Peta throws kado
to the hounds Katniss follows with an
arrow ending his suffering quickly in
the morning a sense of relief washes
over the two tributes as they descend
from the Cornucopia having survived and
achieved Victory together however their
Joy is shortlived when game maker senica
announces a cruel twist only one of them
can be the Victor refusing to be Pawns
in the Capitals game both Katniss and
Peter reach for the poisonous berries
they collected earlier this act of
defiance and potential double suicide
threatens a humiliating ideological
defeat for the capital just in time Sena
relents and declares them both Victors
ending the games on a surprising and
unorthodox note in the wake of their
unexpected Victory hitch cautions
catniss and Peta that the capital won't
tolerate their Defiance lightly he
advises them to maintain their facade of
Love garnering The public's continued
support and ensuring their safety
meanwhile game maker senica responsible
for the disastrous games management
faces his own punishment locked in a
room with only a plate of poisonous
berries as the movie concludes President
Snow's watchful gaze remains fixed on
Katniss and District 12 a dark suspicion
of rebellion brewing in his mind